it is an immersive experience that
encourages guests to experience the
awe-inspiring works of vincent van gogh
on the las vegas strip and they have a
very special announcement here to tell
us more is amy piddle the associate
general manager of immersive van gogh
and luna one of the hosts of the exhibit
welcome you guys thank you you both look
lovely i'm loving the van gogh theme and
i mean can we just talk about this dress
thank you so much oh my goodness well
first of all let's talk about the
experience i first was exposed to it
when i was watching emily in paris and
i'm like what is this this is amazing
and now we have it here in las vegas
tell us a little bit about it well and
in emily in paris that was our exhibit
so we're proud to bring it here to the
las vegas strip we're located at the
shops at crystal so it's a beautiful
venue and yes we're thrilled to have
vincent van gogh featured so so you walk
into this room and it's just all of his
works of art but it's more than just
looking at them it's
living in them can you tell us a little
bit about it luna yes basically you're
able to walk inside of his paintings
with over 64 projectors and 90 million
pixels you're taking on a 35 minute
adventure throughout his artworks and
almost most popular artworks as well
we hear you've had some pretty exciting
guests come to the exhibit yeah any
anyone um famous that has visited lately
well we did have bts one of the members
of bts stop in and it was yep yes one of
the members j-hope actually
david copperfield yes that i mean
everybody who's anyone comes to this
exhibit now for those of you that
haven't seen it you're actually doing
something very special for pride month
can you tell us a little bit about that
we're thrilled to be uh supporting the
lgbtq community and we are offering a
discount a special right now it's called
pride 50.
that's the discount code and we're
offering 50 off any and all tickets
unlimited quantities and that's through
july 21st wow that is quite a deal and
so you make a reservation and then you
go at your time and then you have a
certain amount of time that you get to
spend in there is that whole world
actually we'll let people stay as long
as they like oh you heard it here yeah
amy and luna told us you can stay as
long as you need to stay now you have a
pretty cool artist-in-residence program
yes for local artists tell us a little
bit about that so basically if you are
an artist in las vegas we encourage you
to apply on van gogh vegas.com and the
artist in residence category therefore
you can showcase your art at our venue
and even sell it as well oh that's
brilliant now just on a personal level
what are your favorite works of art by
mango i actually like starry roan as you
can see right over here with a beautiful
color that i have oh you look
spectacular i've always loved irises
it's just an amazing experience so make
sure you take advantage of the special
deal again what is it one more time 50
and that's the code to put in to get the
tickets okay definitely check oh and
where is it located again in crystals
shops and crystals are proud to be there
and on the beautiful las vegas strip oh
definitely something you have to check
off the bucket list amazing you can
check out immersive van gogh again at
the shops at crystals and don't forget
this pride special 50 discount off all
ticket prices in celebration of pride
month through july 21